Speaker 1: Herschel Walker. Our friend
Herschel Walker was asked about the economy
and his answer was completely unintelligent
and unintelligible as well. Now,
I want to kind of remind you guys of the context
here. Herschel Walker is the Republican Senate
candidate from Georgia. He's running against
incumbent Democratic Senator Raphael Warnock.
Recently, Walker weighed in on such issues as 911
foreign policy as well as education. And none of
his opinions made any sense. And yet he is now
leading against Raphael Warnock. Most recently,
Walker appeared on the Newsmax Show. Spicer and
Company. Yes, with Sean Spicer. Trump's short
lived, sort of short lived press secretary when
he was president. And his answer doesn't make any
sense about the economy. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: Helping spend more in Democrats,
spend more voting on some of those bills.
How are you talking about this spending?
Is it a winning issue in Georgia?
Speaker 5: Well, it is a winning
issue. It is the economy is a winning issue
because I think anyone with any type of sense
and I hate to say it if people on a level I have
sense, but, you know, you don't spend what you
don't have. Right. There seem to be what the
left has gotten good at and continue to spend
the people's money. And this will be good stewards
with people money and they seem to know how to do
that. And also crime, you know, going up, crime
has really gotten terrible. And, you know, I'm
running against a man that called our officers,
our men and women in Blue Dogs and yeah, helping.
Speaker 1: So his view on the economy is
don't spend what you don't have and crime
as well now. This guy is winning this race,
and that's completely outrageous. But I want
to I spotted a very interesting comment on our
subreddit from user Mr. Y Dubon. Okay. Mr. Y Dubon
sort of tried to explain why Walker is doing well
in his race and what Mr. Weidman said as Herschel
Walker is expressing the human mental state after
consuming thousands of hours of right wing media.
And when we hear these word salads from Herschel
Walker, according to this Reddit user, it
resonates with this frenzied mental state of the
target audience, the people that are just furious,
they don't even know why, but they're furious and
they're scared and they're angry because they've
been watching Fox News and Newsmax, which is
designed to agitate. It's designed to make
people agitated and angry by pressing these
buttons. And all you need to do to press the
buttons is to say these things. And if you want to
interpret it that way, when Herschel Walker goes
money we don't have and crime, it's a crazy thing.
It's just it's all over the place. It's frenetic,
but it's just pushing those buttons of the very
people that it's designed to. And I think that
that's a very it's an astute comment, quite
frankly. Herschel Walker also talking about
how he's not doing this for money. He's not
running for money. Who does that remind you of?
Speaker 5: When I get in Washington, I'm not
going to go to Washington like Senator Obama
has done to try to build my income. I've been
blessed through the Lord Jesus to make money.
So I'm not going to Washington to make money.
Speaker 1: Yeah, sounds a lot like what Donald
Trump was saying in 2016. I don't need this. I
don't I could just hang out and be fine. I'm I
don't need the money. I won't even take my
salary. And we know how that worked out,
raping and pillaging all sorts of institutions and
resources of the United States. So when I hear I
don't really need the money from doing this,
to me it only raises red flags because it's so
Trumpian. If you're listening today and you
want to see these clips in their full glory,
we'll have them on our Instagram. That's
at David Parkman Show on Instagram.